[Music]
many times have I seen this woman cry no
sad-looking dude is terrible man cuz she
laughed so much on a regular basis when
she cries it's like it's like that
person never cries and then once they
opened the [ __ ] funny
non-stop when he said hi
goddamnit like pudding mix it up
horrible where's your sexy thing show
them your sexy face okay there it is
that's a compliment that's how huge it
is and went straight to her stomach is
it your goal to get me wasted and SH
wasted time tell me why your face is
like a direct butthole how about that oh
really nasty how many times have you
licked my face spit on your head put it
oh you are such a big boob art seriously
does she always do this everytime I try
on the camera she acts like she's a
victim
[Laughter]
I'm slightly buzzed here goes to the
Mexican [ __ ] okay okay
poor people and us me us whatever okay
Tendo way before way hey I like how the
bonito dances when it cooks bunny
[Music]
ever was 11 right now so basically we've
been talking about why people should
shave their pubic area right guys
basically because girls tend to do it
more than guys do now part has a reason
what he won't do it that but what's the
reason it's funny because when people
also don't know is that he has to cut
his fingernails and toenails in the same
environment
[Laughter]
whoever a high schooler very like books
about birds it specifically says Bart
quas pubes are used to fortify the
houses of all the places she wants me to
shave it in the bathroom
but is that an actual fact though so one
of the biggest I said you're beautiful
so no joke if he would if he would
eliminate this okay fine
from a scale of sea urchin to Osama bin
Laden what does it look like a James
Harden so you can braid
but you know what the worst part is for
guys so like no but listen oh no no no
no this goes for you this works for you
because once the guy shades it and you
let it grow out again it's annoying to
shave it again so you might just keep
doing it consistently please so
technically it's your fault then because
with or without hair you still give it
to him so every time you do it you have
to just take a small little baby oh that
exactly
cuz what a girl's uh-huh and I spread
sometimes I'd like dude that's [ __ ]
love people it literally sounds like
when you have a paper shredder and then
you're scrambling through to find the
pieces that's no [ __ ] funny so the
reason why you don't give them is
because you don't like them that's
really no joke that's like
so the frequency is really low cuz you
just hate that's so odd because usually
if a girl says listen I will blow you
every [ __ ] day if you shave it the
next thing you know they're bald how
about you just go for one day and just
whip out a razor as you're sucking them
off and then my family that hugs
together stays together oh my God look
at this family moment it's so beautiful
it's like two worlds colliding quarter
chopped up boba I think do you love your
mom
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is what we have been waiting for
apparently this is a very mandatory pit
stop here to have this ice cream this is
matcha green-tea and vanilla as you guys
may well know I [ __ ] love ice cream
ice cream is one of my favorite desserts
I don't like desserts too much but when
it comes to ice cream it's my ship can
we talk about this for a moment
creamy and the great thing about this
you could actually place the matcha
powder which in America when you have a
lot of stuff that's matcha green tea
flavored it doesn't taste like matcha
it's bomb what's your favorite thing
about it though it actually tastes like
much that too unlike exactly she's good
[Laughter]
I'm making it worse
I get the [ __ ] ice cream off your
chin you can't feel my toes I said we
walked around for probably a plus one
1012 hours I have no idea but my feet
are dying right now it's very fun for
stage of Japan we went to Shibuya and we
also into Shinjuku
I think I can't remember right now all I
know is that my feet are killing me my
kneecaps hurt and this is the reason why
you don't have fat people in Japan
because if you're fat you would get
around nowhere sad part on a side note
there was a beautiful little girl on a
wheelchair and she basically told my fat
ass to get out the way and pass my ass
up at least an extra 7 miles per hour
so that was a low point in my life but
we are back home tomorrow's another day
another adventure I'll see you all next
time didn't I
[Music]